vielleicht fehlen flügelaltars dem
rücken von herzlich kommt zu einem neuen
video heute probieren wir wir im titel
schon gesehen hatte könnt ihr alle lesen
oder sieben verrücktesten süßigkeiten
wie man heute bei fast und haben da
einiges gesehen richtig seltsame sachen
teilweise und dann habe ich mir gedacht
schnappe ich mir doch einfach mal die
gestörten die sich sonst keinem argument
kaufen würde und probiert die heute für
euch mit der bezaubernden co-moderator
[Musik]
ich bin hinter der kamera an mein name
ist frank förster und ich mache alles
klar wer mir ganze sieben wichtigkeit
mal anfangen das ist recht ungewöhnlich
ist so ihr kind durch dieses stang vom
jahrmarkt und das ist einfach so ein
gestörter mix und 20.000 verschiedenen
aber auch genau wie das original
jammerte wird seite füllung hey leute
wollte meinen guten wetter lässt in
slums
kinder
dort brechen würde sie ja mal was
schmeckt auch ein bisschen anders wird
mit dem fest ein süßigkeiten experten
sagen
seine 15 auf der geschmackstage auf der
verrückte aber sozusagen geschmack ja
ich kann mir vorstellen dass das keine
es geht uns verrückt skala wird in der
form von spiralen deswegen als nächstes
mal dass hier leute was er drauf
kaugummi wissen einfach denn ich bei der
etwa kenne ich leider nicht richtig geil
aus das ist ein riesengroßes klassischen
richtig geschmack richtig scheiße ich
würd sagen eine zwei- oder eine
einführung und verrücktheit schon
dreieinhalb boklok mit hugo boss macht
ermöglichen
in unserem land
dann wird das nichts aus das ist einfach
eine fucking toilette aber ab bei
süßigkeiten immergrün belm immer grün
wählen er kommt auf so eine scheißidee
man ist einfach eine kleine plastik
toilette okay diese fleißig toilette
gibt man diese aus und die leute ihre
tätigkeit eine toilette reinstecken wäre
das doch wirklich gelüftet
saure spülung disclosure act sauer 60
junge buchen des coop die gegend so
ähnlich wie ein anderes volk zu
entschärfen
nein ich will stärker sollte das werk
setzen könnte ein richtiges lüften
das krasse ist die dinger gehen auch
bisschen aussieht und toiletten könnte
und wenn möglich sind hält die junge
dame kommt denn auf so eine stelle aus
leute denkt darüber nach zuletzt die
klobürste ab wichtig für eine klobürste
wie eine öffentliche toilette die ist
das ein jahr jünger als die börsianer an
das sind genutzt heute so schwer ist wie
eine abgefallene nicht auf eine schule
auf dem pausenhof eine klobürste in
kloten auf 605 aber geschmack
und hier sehen wir auch schon das
nächste an zwei kennen das bestimmt
eigentlich arbeit gestört
die idee an sich ist gefragt meinst du
magst überhaupt nicht so ekelhaft wo ich
früher mal probiert ob ich spielen sagt
das buch von maxi user entweder zu
werden kann das gibt weil es einfach
verpasst das ist ein klassiker aber
trotzdem ziemlich kreativ muss man als
nächstes nebenher ein von popcorn
einhorn
aber ich bin jung rundfahrt dafür sieht
aus als hätte sich irgendwie so eine fee
in der nähe von popcorn maschine in die
luft
sollte sie das in wacken die vielleicht
fehlen flügelaltar aus seiner rücken
dieses programm in pinken zucker
versehen wurde ich mag ich deswegen
nicht hier weil ich bekomme zwar nicht
mehr aber von der verrückten auch rein
optisch vom aussehen her würde ich auch
mit 4gb abgespeckt aussieht aber es ist
einfach voll die ab 20 punkte vom der
verrückte skala
dann kommen wir zum nächsten und zwar
haben wir hier ja kaugummi mit ketchup
füllung aber auch würden bürger
schmitten
was sich dabei gedacht haben dass wir
drin
abgefragt idee alte toilette man
eigentlich will ich dafür draußen was
denkt ihr eigentlich von der schweiz aus
papier nicht so eine scheiße aus kaffee
kaffee zucker pur
dafür gibt es ganz klar ist aber
komplett zuletzt wichtigkeit leute denn
der hat ganz normal vorbereitet und zwar
was die passenden stäbchen leute und
jana sagen wir haben ja einfach drauf
liegt ja wissen aber dass 2010 das gar
nicht feiern darf man ja ich glaube
schon richtig dass nicht nur der größte
sich die fans der welt das heißt wenn
süßigkeiten bis jetzt auch noch die
molkerei wollen den gegner will
ebenfalls macht das sogar seetang salat
ist aber auch international meistens
kommt wenn man bestellt wurde jetzt mal
dass wir raus sind das hier ist in 101
die dinger von vorne das sind die
jahrmarkt schnüre alters der boxen oder
fax
der winterdienst des rangiert das
rangiert jetzt richtig eklig anzusehen
während ich mir dieses wesen schnüre in
meinen mund für alle geben jede
verpackung für geschmack und für
verrückt gebe ich fünf war das ist auch
dass man ordentlich gemacht hat mal mit
gefressen hast du kannst setzen
reformieren und wenn die anders ist
könnt ihr einfach hier oben altes video
abchecken hier und meine abonnieren oder
hier oben die neuen formaten gehen sie
mit einem zuschlag von kamera